I'm excited to talk today about both
telegraphy and Apache pulsar I've been
working with pulsar for a little over a
year at mostly at the previous company I
worked at and then now with a pretty
ambitious side project I'm working on
and so yeah I wanted to kind of show how
something historical like The Telegraph
kind of contributes to what we're
designing today as far as the
distributed pub/sub system so as far as
an agenda goes first I'm gonna talk
about myself introduce myself I guess
not for very long because that's the
most boring part of this talk and then
talk a little bit about history with
what the electric telegraph or wireless
Telegraph then talk about pulsar some of
the internal design considerations there
why those decisions were made and kind
of what value that those bring how I
I've used pulsar and how others use
pulsar as well and talking about the
future of pulsar and if I have time I
have a demo that I will also show pulsar
working I ran through this a couple
times before and depending on how fast I
speak sometimes I have time sometimes I
don't so if you're interested in in the
demo if I don't get to it happy to show
it to you it's mostly ingest so it's
nothing nothing it's too crazy if you're
not if you're worried about missing out
on it and then at the end I'll take
questions if I have time as well I'm if
I don't then feel free to either catch
me on Twitter on there a lot or email
I'll provide those details at the end if
you would like to do that so this is a
much better picture of me than any
picture I could take with the camera and
I'm a software engineer Pluralsight out
of curiosity how many people here have
used or heard of Pluralsight great
before I worked at Pluralsight I worked
at a company no one ever heard of so
it's always embarrassing whenever I come
to speak at conferences because I don't
have to try to
playing what the company did and if you
ever explained what your company does
even something like Pluralsight it's not
a good time especially when it's like a
non-technical audience and you work on
data infrastructure it's they usually
bad bad time I live in Salt Lake City
and flora cites headquartered there it's
a very very not diverse place but that's
okay now there are some other good
things about it like the low cost of
living and snowboarding if you like that
which I don't but yeah and the other
there's a growing tech sector there so
Pluralsight like went public last year
we've got like three or four other tech
companies over the last couple years so
it's a decent place to live I mean I
looked like it but I do cycle so Road
biking I used to be like 50 pounds
lighter but I'm getting back into it
trying to get back into what I call
speedo shape and I'll see if I can get
there and then I got in a model rocketry
this year with the 50th anniversary of
the Apollo moon landing and that's been
great it's been I got burned a couple
times it's a good time to get in the
model rocketry alright so with that I'll
forget and get into the kind of weed
guts of my talk so I think there's been
a couple talks that I've attended today
that have said this but the history of
computing and of communication in
general is probably under examined field
in our industry and there's a lot that
we can kind of learn from looking back
into the past and you're trying to
harken lessons from that and in this
case as I worked with pulsar I started
reading this book it's it's called the
Victorian Internet and it's basically a
history of telegraphy so from kind of
the earliest incarnations of it to the
the latest before it kind of retired and
actually you could send Telegraph's up
until like ten years ago
it was it's kind of stuck around for a
really long time and in reading this
book and actually kind of looking at the
title it strikes me as pretty intro
thing that the author referred to it as
the Victorian Internet
and it really did suffice to kind of be
that during its heyday so people would
send the equivalent of like SMS or text
messages through through that and I'll
kind of talk about some more usages in a
second but it was in in an era where you
know people were really ugly clothes had
really bland food they were able to kind
of come up with something
technologically that was really
interesting and there are a lot of
lessons that we kind of learned from
from this technology so here's kind of a
I guess a vector artist's rendering of a
telegraph
so I guess to be kind of pedantic
there's sort of several ways that you
can do to lag Rafi so there's one the
kind of more well-known is that you can
actually just send plain text so you can
just kind of write write a note and then
that I can get passed on and then the
second way which is probably the more
common way people think about it is
through Morse code which I'll get into
in a second so what one of the I guess
the downsides of using one of these
systems is the the transmission cost so
this is like a switchboard so if you
were sending a telegraph to me and you
lived one part of the network and I
lived another part of the network this
kind of switching what happens you
basically would send it to one of these
switchboards and then they were to route
it to me
and so you can see kind of quickly that
while that is somewhat efficient there's
also a few holes in in that that way of
sending data so number one like any of
these nice people here sending them
could could read your message so if you
had something private that you wanted to
say which a lot of people did so one of
the things I was covered in that
Victorian internet book is that early
editions of online dating so like your
Victorian era era tinder happened
through this so you know people would
send
somewhat explicit messages through
through these services and you know some
of these switch operators would just
kind of read them and get a chuckle out
of them because they they knew is like
going from point A to point B and all
their messages that just kind of
explicit so they'd kind of read through
it and even more than that
so another thing you can always kind of
expect with new communication mechanisms
is organized crime so organized crime
rings liked Telegraph's because they
could you know be on separate sides of
the country and kind of organize their
activities if you've ever seen the
television show The Wire on HBO they
they use cell phones for this they call
them burners and they they used to kind
of transact on all their drug deals but
you know in the Victorian era that this
sort of the way that you would you would
do this and yeah this is just people
that are making moonshine so that's also
a good time so one way to kind of get
around people reading your messages is
to create a cipher so that would
essentially be like encryption so that
only the person sending it kind of
encrypts the message and then the person
receiving it knows how to decrypt it and
so during the kind of popularity of
telegraphy you these kinds of books that
would be explaining how to decipher and
to encode and decode messages were
relatively common and the the problem
with it is that when when you only have
like characters like text to use you can
kind of do like Pig Latin or some other
variation and try to translate it but
they're pretty easy to figure out so
some of the organized crime mobs of the
time would you know make ciphers and
then the government would figure it out
and then figure out where people were
meeting and kind of bust them that way
so this this is not not ideal either but
at the kind of height of telegraphy this
was the release this one company their
service map so if you wanted to you can
send a message from anywhere and sort
the furthest west to the furthest East
or furthest north the furthest
but if you're sending a message you
might hit several switch operators and
doing that and also what what you will
will notice about that it's not only the
privacy issue but also there could be
message quality issues because if
someone has to pass that along and they
could kind of distort the message in
doing that so I guess the so they're
more famous I guess usages of
Telegraph's were these tape messages so
if you think about something like the
New York Stock Exchange it's essentially
like a never-ending sort of ticker of
data and the first kind of renditions of
this were with the Telegraph so you
could at the beginning of the day in New
York start tracking all the stocks for
the different companies and send that on
the telegraph and then all the
subscribers downstream across the
country could know what the price of
those stocks were throughout the day so
it was a pretty powerful medium I'm also
breaking news the way that you get on
Twitter came through this mechanism as
well so you could find out who won the
presidency for example or you could find
out I don't know people were doing back
then people were owning slaves I guess
was one of the things they're doing but
you know that that's all things that
people how people were communicating and
so and I guess another example I've
written down my notes here it's like
meeting minutes so if you had a u.s.
geographically distributed company or
actually if you had one unlike London
and you had a company in Europe because
there were some transcontinental
networks as well
you can send meetings meeting notes
across it'd be kind of an expensive
thing to do but it was possible so this
is a example of kind of a late late era
Telegraph and this is one that used
Morse code so I'll just kind of show a
Morse code looked like so it's just a
way to express language in dots
essentially so you could translate a
a letter or some other longer text into
these dots and then you can communicate
wirelessly over radio instead of with
the wired network like the original
telegraph so this enabled kind of kind
of solve some of the problems that were
with the wire Telegraph but kinda
introduced a whole new slew of problems
as well so we can talk about kind of
these problems and then I'm gonna use
this as a jumping board it's a switch
over to pulsar and talk about how pulsar
is sort of similar to this and then how
it addresses these specific problems so
data storage so if you were to think
about receiving a telegraph and you
wanted to you didn't write it down for
example and then you wanted to I replay
every Telegraph that you had in the past
for whatever reason that there's going
to be some issues with that or if you
wanted to collect other Telegraph's that
people were sending they might be issues
with that as well so data transmission
so if you if there are any problems in
the network that would be hard hard to
receive messages and there there were
some other issues around the ciphering
so if you want to ensure that your data
is secure kind of going through the wire
it's pretty hard to do in the telegraph
age multi casting is also difficult so
if you had several subscribers that you
wanted to send messages to in in the
wire Telegraph age that were required
you know having physical switchboards
kind of connect you and then in the
wireless Telegraph age they required as
soon as there's a radio frequency it's
kind of understand knowing the radio
frequency of what what you're
subscribing to encryption we kind of
talked about and then delivery
guarantees so in the in the wireless
Telegraph Network there there's pretty
much no guarantees and then the wired
one there was a and at most once
guarantee re at least once guarantee so
they would try to resend your message if
you called and complained and said that
you didn't receive it so you could get
it or you could get it twice like they
didn't think that they they sent it
you as well so with computers which we
have now in our beautiful age how can we
use those to kind of enhance the what
telegraphy promised us and kind of fix
the the problems they're in is what I'm
going to talk about next
so Apache pulsar is a it's part of the
Apache Software Foundation and it came
out of Yahoo and it's a it's a
distributed pub/sub system that's
focused on a few things so one of the
things that it is focused on is being
globally distributed so if if you have
data centers across the world and you're
trying to have kind of a unified looking
publish/subscribe system that's what
pulsar is designed to do it's also well
I'm going to get into in a second a
couple of the design to sitter
considerations and how those solve that
list of problems but it's got a
reasonable logo I work with a lot of
Apache projects for my job and a lot of
logos are bad right then this one's okay
it it definitely looks like it's
designed by a back-end engineer but it's
okay it's not we can work with it so
let's talk a little bit about the sort
of basic architecture of pulsar oh okay
so we'll talk about the the basic
architecture of pulsar so pulsar
consists mainly if you look at the
bottom here at the pulsar nodes these
are brokers that as a brokers that as a
user connecting to pulsar this is the
interaction point that you'd have sort
of the the client experience that you
would connect to the nodes and then it
has the second component which is called
bookkeeper and bookkeeper is how pulsar
stores its data so this is a pretty
unique approach in in terms of both
subscribed systems usually the data is
stored on the nodes themselves by pulsar
intentionally sourced them separately
and I'll get into why in a second and
then in the top here it has this thing
called zookeeper which is essentially to
help coordinate all this so because this
is distributed it there's a lot of
failure modes with what distributed
software and a lot of problems that
arise and zookeeper is essentially there
to help understand the state of the of
the cluster at any point so that you can
make decisions and I'll get into that
those architecture decisions and kind of
what those ramifications are in in a
second okay so let's review our problem
so we're gonna talk data storage
transmission multi casting encryption
delivery guarantees and so we'll start
with data storage so in in general so
like in the wireless telegraphy case we
kind of talked about what the
limitations of storage would be in that
case like there's no database of your
Telegraph's there's no way to you know
keep a distinct order of when you
receive them if you wanted to replay
them so for example if you're trying to
tell a story about something like if you
were in court and you said I think this
person committed this crime because I
have this Telegraph I have these several
Telegraph's and I want to use them to
make this person seem guilty
you have to kind of stitch that story
back together and there's not like a
logical ordering per se so the first
thing that pulsar is which also Kafka
does this as well if you use them as an
immutable log so essentially every
message that gets written gets written
to a log that has some ordering
guarantees and then also has some
specifics about how data is written out
of that so as far as the the storage
architecture I've talked about this a
second ago most systems that that try to
do this will keep the storage and the
brokers that communicate with clients
together so an architecture that kind of
looks like this where you have up to n
brokers and some kind of communication
mechanism between them
and then you have storage on each of
those and brokers and so with this
architecture there are some limitations
to this so as far as the storage goes
since it's coupled with your nodes then
the most so if you have any problems
that are like unrelated to storage or
you had no problems so you had no
problems that unrelated to storage or
storage problems are unrelated to your
nodes thing and it's going to be this a
similar problem and so if you want to
scale out storage
that also means scaling up nodes so
pulsar instead takes this approach so
and you can scale up your nodes and your
storage separately so if you have really
expensive messages for example
so like the payloads that you receive
are large then maybe you want to scale
up your storage but maybe the volume is
in this big so you can keep the that are
sorry maybe the volume of messages so
like how many messages you're getting
it's in its large so you can keep that
much smaller so that that's kind of
mostly the approach of pulsar and book
bookkeepers used in other systems so
bookkeeper is used in Hadoop and you'll
see it around it's also used in another
distributed pub a subsystem called I
can't quite remember the name of it but
another great feature of pulsar is
because the SEP the this storage is
separated from the nodes then that you
can do interesting things with the
storage so pulsar has this thing called
tiered storage and essentially is if you
if you think about bookkeeper as kind of
a hot storage like what happens in
exactly now so all the data that is
being written to your nodes are in there
but you know as the data gets older
pulsar can actually automatically
archive that to a different system like
s3 which is much cheaper to store then
on you know disks that you need to kind
of keep alive in a bookkeeper cluster
and then even even more so it can push
that into glacier which is even slower
storage making
but the interesting thing about this is
that despite you know having three
different storage mechanisms if you were
as a client wanted to read older data
from pulsar the API would be still be
the same
so in this case like if you had data and
a topic that went all the way back to
like years and it was in glacier and you
said hey give me all the data from this
topic it will do it and it will just
kind of manage the connect and s3 and
connecting the glacier so this is
something that actually did a lot at the
previous company I worked at we had
several petabytes of data and we
generated several terabytes per month
and so keeping it all in bookkeeper was
too much and so having this API and this
kind of storage layer that was much
better
so it's a flexible way to to kind of
manage the storage of messages which
telegraphy didn't really have you know
most of the storage mechanism was you
know putting those receipts of the the
Telegraph into a filing cabinet maybe in
some kind of monotonic order or
something like that okay so we solve
that problem next we're going to talk
about data transmission so data
transmission so how data gets you know
into pulsar and out of pulsar is it's
pretty important and how it differs from
the from the Telegraph is something I'll
describe as well so pulsars main
mechanism of controlling data is is
through a schema registry so Apache
Kafka has a similar concept it's
basically a contract that says you know
if you're sending data to this topic
it's going to look like this it's gonna
have this schema so every message that
gets written the pulsar gets checked
against a schema registry and then it
gets written the book keeper if it
passes that check so in this case in
this example it just has like you know
to arbitrary fields and so every message
that gets sent from a client to any one
of the know
would get shape against the the schema
registry and the most common way to
encode data into pulsar it would be
through Avro so you can do
Avro or JSON schema but Avril was way
more common how many people here if you
use Avro out of curiosity okay so it's
pretty pretty well-known basic ever a
schema kind of looks like this so you
know you have a namespace and then some
fields and the one of the reasons why
you would use Avro over another
mechanism is because a schema evolution
so for example if you and in this case
what we're saying is explicitly every
message that ID or every message has an
ID field and a username field an ID
field is int type and the username feels
a string type but if you were to get
null data it wouldn't really handle that
well and so it actually wouldn't write
it at all in the pulsar case and so you
can evolve your schema which basically
in this case like we're gonna say that
usernames are allowed to be null so this
would effectively make it so that any
any new data is still conformant to that
schema and so that it may essentially
makes it so that you can think about
your schema it's not so static which
could be pretty detrimental and a
message passing case when you know there
are lots of different uses that you can
see in the future but you know with with
some slight tweaks you can get kind of
more mileage out of it okay so we
handled those two multi casting excuse
me so multi casting essentially as if
you want to communicate to multiple
consumers the same message so in this
case like the red circle wants to send
the same message to several green
circles but not the yellow ones because
they are not subscribers and so in our I
guess modern world we there's there's a
lot of reasons to send these kinds of
multicast messages like multiple people
on a
group text chain for example which I
think everyone dislikes group text I
definitely do
I've never had a had a good experience
or you know slack something like that or
to manage kind of the kind of multiple
needs of different consumers which this
drawing is supposed to kind of
illustrate so as far as how pulsar
handles this this is a little bit
smaller I apologize is barred from
pulsars docks essentially if you're a
producer so you're someone sending data
to a topic you you know multiple
producers can you know send data to the
same topic and then that that topic can
have subscriptions and then you know
each consumer can subscribe to you know
one or multiple topics essentially so
you know that that's the way that Apache
Kafka handles it and other systems like
this as well but you know in in the case
of you know telegraphy they didn't have
a way to do this kind of multi casting
that easily but you know in our modern
age with the computers we can do it much
better okay so oh I want that cast it's
not crosstown keyway on my slides okay
so as far as encryption goes if you're
sending messages from a client to pulsar
and then people are consuming those
messages on the other side you know
encrypting that data would be of value
so out of the box
pulsar supports this regular SSL so yeah
this is just kind of a little
description of how or a little example
of how that works
pulsar also has some other security
mechanisms as well if you want to enable
those I haven't actually used anything
besides SSL because it works so simply
and this way you won't have the same
problem as the gangster's I guess you
know trying to send their messages in
the telegraph world you can send them
through pulsar although the NSA might be
able to intercept them still so that's
another for another day I guess so
delivery guarantees so when you are a
client and you
send a message to pulsar and it's
acknowledged what kind of guarantees can
you expect you know in The Telegraph
case there weren't very strong
guarantees so was this kind of no
guarantee situation where you could send
multiple messages as a client and then
there's no real guarantee that you're
the party downstream would send it
actually in the in the Victorian
internet book in the early days of
telegraphy there people would send like
a telegraph and the letter because they
would kind of expect that there was some
you know nonzero chance that it just
wouldn't get to wherever they were
sending it so yeah that's kind of
embarrassing so so then then the kind of
doing a little bit better is that most
once so you know you will try to send it
and and maybe receive may not be
received but you're not going to try to
send it again first and then the at
least once would be you're gonna try to
guarantee that it's sent but that might
mean that you're gonna send the same
message multiple times and then exactly
once which when I was coming up with
this illustration that it's kind of
funny because the iPhone definitely
doesn't do this so I received multiple
messages a lot of times but that the
concept is that you know you can kind of
guarantee that if you have a message in
its acknowledged from the Pulsar
consumer or sorry the Pulsar node then
it's it's gonna be gonna be in there one
time and not multiple time so pulsar
actually supports both of these
semantics or at least once and exactly
once
it just depends on how much lates into
you that you want to add to the overall
system so in order to get that kind of
exactly once guarantee they're just
going to be need to be a lot more
acknowledgments whereas in the at least
once you know you don't have to have as
many and so you might have to have a
case where multiple messages get and
push through alright so with the last
few minutes I have I want to talk about
stream processing so once you have data
in pulsar and what you can do with it
from that
point onward so one of the main ways
that you can do stream processing and
Paul starts with a pulsar sequel so
pulsar because the whole architecture is
designed to be pluggable or kind of like
Legos and you can add pieces to it as
you need
pulsar sequel is essentially adding an
embedded presto
which is presto is this distributed
sequel anything query engine so
essentially adding an embedded presto to
your pulsar architecture and then that
enables you to do sequel on top of your
topics so effectively you just send the
sequel queries and then presto we'll
just kind of handle that and this
actually will work even in the case
where your data is in s3 some of its in
s3 some of it's in glacier so this API
will just kind of sequel over the whole
thing
so make a query plan that would manage
it so in in pulsars case the the data
and kind of where it's stored is
included in the metadata of each message
so as far as presto is concerned it can
kind of stitch together like an
intelligent enough query plan to do that
and this is from the Pulsar Docs so this
is a little bit more sort of insight
into that that kind of presto worker and
presto embedded presto Engine so
effectively you know Matt no matter what
data you've got so if you think about
this this is like a real time data
coming in and you also have data that's
stored across multiple engines so if you
did like a select star for example then
you would need to get all data through
history and then also keep tailing the
new data and yeah that's that's exactly
the way that that Presto's designed to
manage that so alternatively pulsar has
pulsar functions so pulsar functions are
a service function implementation that
runs on the Pulsar nodes themselves so
the the key things to consider with
pulsar functions are that at the moment
they only have one
one input one output so they can only
you know consume from a pulsar topic and
then they write out to one or more
pulsar topics so you see so I'll get in
this a second but but like when more we
were using it we wanted to have some
more advanced uses just where we would
like go out and to other things but at
the moment this is kind of the usage so
to kind of reiterate that this is an
illustration so it's kind of hard to see
but there's like a little FN on the
Pulsar nodes so the functions actually
run on those nodes and probably some of
you are thinking okay well that might be
like a resource issue so like pulsar is
supposed to be trying to manage the
connections and like keep everything
acknowledged keep ordering across the
topics like how is it also running these
functions like what what available space
is there to do that and pulsars also JDM
so even even more so I how is it doing
that so effectively in the kind of the
naive approach it's it's just running
taking resources up in its own sorry
name space but in if you wanted to add
more isolation the more recent additions
of pulsar you can actually run those and
docker if you want and then I failed to
mention that pulsar functions you can
write them in Java you can write them in
Python and with the most recent release
of pulsar you can also write them and go
if you would like and then those will
essentially consume consume messages
from a topic and then you know push them
to another topic this is a go example
from the docs or is actually from the
repository there's a big example in
there so you don't need tons of code so
all this is steering is pulling in the
pulsar go client and then connecting to
this my topic and then doing a loop and
in writing a hello at what the counter
attached to it and I'm writing it to
another topic so
okay so but as far as the future is
concerned you know what what I look
forward to with pulsar so this is
something that I am pretty excited about
and trying to work on as well is the
ability for pulsar functions to have
sinks outside of pulsar so if I wanted
to use my pulsar function to write data
to elasticsearch or couch or cockroach
DB or like Google file system or
whatever that that I would be able to do
that so right now you can't see
effectively you would have to write to
another topic and then have another
process that did this but that would
simplify things quite a bit
to allow that and then as far as things
I'd like to try in the future as well so
this is in the java land but since
pulsar functions are are either just
java just go or just python and they're
just in the java case it's a jar and the
go case is a binary and python case it's
just the Python file you can import
libraries and do all sorts of
interesting things so in my case I'd be
interested in trying machine learning or
doing some better regex
because a lot of the topics we'll have
you know now form data and you know
being able to kind of clean those up
pass them on to another topic it's
something that we're looking looking
forward to doing so I do have a few
minutes so I'm gonna go ahead and try to
do this demo real quick
so let's I'm gonna move this that
totally didn't work okay so
this is this is stream Leo so streaming
as a company that runs managed apache
pulsar and they have a managed demo that
you can do so if you want to just try
pulsar this is one of the better places
to try it because you don't have to deal
with all of the architecture and
hardware that i would take to run it so
at the moment I have a few topics I've
got one pulsar function and then I've
got one source so so the source I have
is this actually can't see that too well
but it's it's writing data to this RSS
topic which can come in here and take a
look at that
so if we look at the schema actually
that's probably harder to see I'll do
this okay so the data that Skinner into
this looks roughly like this it's a
bunch of address name and other personal
artifact data so what I'm gonna do is
create a pulsar function that will look
at the code
so all this pulse to our function does
is take the input which is each of those
JSON blobs and then I'm ripping out
first name last name and social security
number and this is what I'm calling my
NSA topic so I'm effectively just
ripping ripping that data out and then
publishing that data to a new topic so
if we come back to topics and look at an
essay topic and then look at one of
these partitions yeah we can see that I
just basically took all of took the
first day in the last name and the
social security number there I'm just
printed this topic for some nefarious
cause later so oh okay so if you want to
try pulsar you can check out the docs
you could try it locally by pulling it
down on docker or thaka compose or you
could try free stretch trial extremely
if you want I do not work for streaming
leo I'm friends with them but it's
pretty it's a pretty good way to the use
pulsar and then if you have any
questions I'm at a time but you can stop
me I'll be around I'm pretty easy to
find usually have some kind of like
bright shirt or like flowers so but
thank you for coming to my talk it was a
pleasure speaking
[Applause]